[Musique]
mais
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir la
grande joie le grand bonheur comme à
chaque fois de recevoir à la baratte on
sait le jardinier en chef du château de
versailles six aussi c'est aussi
l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages le dernier
en date dont alon kozé
s'appelle montout de france des bois et
forêts à la baraton bonjour jour très
heureux de venir vous rencontrer comme à
chaque fois mais bon je voudrais en
voisin et en alsace est sympa ça me fait
très plaisir et alors mon tour de france
des bois des forêts alors moi j'ai une
petite anecdote un petit peu personnage
je sais que vous avez pour habitude le
matin de prendre un grand ban forêt avec
un petit verre de sève de bouleau est
votre secret de forme alors je ne sais
pas si c'est mon secret comme je lé fais
quelques temps mais mehalla c'était une
blague mais non mais vous détestez cette
expression d'une forêt peuvent jouer ou
faire modernité c'est le faire le va le
vin de boulot qui m'a bien fait parce
qu'il ya quelques temps à peine j'en
parle avec alain ducasse qui lui voit
tous les jours
et à mes autres j'habite également dans
un parc je vous rappelle et quand
j'ouvre mes fenêtres le matin j'ai
l'impression d'avoir un bac forêt oui
mais vous n'aimez pas cet extrait si je
n'aime pas le terme s'il vaut thérapie
mais j'aime le terme de bar de forêt ban
forêt c'est le terme employé par les
icaunais c'est le bon montrer cette
boulette en banque ferait on s'imprègne
on se plonge mais cette hypothèse depuis
d'abord que je trouve prétentieux mais
pas du tout bon bref tout est vrai tout
13 sauf le petit verre de jus de bouleau
oui je ne bois pas tous les jours mais
il m'est arrivé d'en boire au printemps
c'est bon quand lass est remonté paraît
que cette excellente c'est ce qui
justifiait ce ce cette forme et hollande
à la ducasse qui cotait 0 le même âge
qu'elle a du coeur et il fait beau non
non vous faite une marche oui mais vous
avez vu sur l'activité débordante j'ai
fait c'est votre émission on parle de
vous dacca alors vous avez sorti donc ce
livre donc votre amour des forêts est
toujours bien présent évidemment le
dictionnaire amoureux des arbres c'était
chez plon en 21 est ce que c'est un peu
une suite est ce que c'est
comme c'est simple c'est que c'est une
série de logique j'ai parlé des jardins
j'ai parlé des arbres il est normal
maintenant que je parle de la forêt des
bois le végétal qu'ils soient plantés ou
pas qu'il soit naturel ou pas contribué
à l'environnement qu'on appelle naturel
un jardin finalement c'est un petit peu
de nature au coeur de la ville où
souffre d'être donc la forêt se devait
d'être explorées mais là attention
actionnaires et j'ai tout un livre
botanique l'agencé bois je parle des
forêts j'en parle des kangoo que l'on
trouve dans les forêts de rentrer je
parle de de l'origine du mot debout faut
se repose oui alors justement parce
qu'on départ vous démarrez votre livre
par là pour être faut se reposer se
trouve être à vercel qu'est ce que ça
veut dire fou ce report déjà j'ai voulu
débuter par cette forêt parce que je
suis presque né dans cette forêt mes
parents avaient une maison maman il vit
toujours pas été bûcheron novembre qui
va à la celle saint cloud dans la forêt
de fond se repose on est jeune ce nom
parce qu'elle est très évocateur
soûlerie 15 et de la quantité de chasse
à courre et la forêt de fausse vraie
pause à pour territoire à terrain qui
est vallonné et couvertes de bosquets et
gamme et 15es et l'âme aider les
chasseurs qu'ils poursuivaient insert
celui ci au bout d'un certain temps
croyez avoir largué ses poursuivants de
par la configuration du terrain erreur
le cerf s'arrêter de courir il se
reposait c'était pour lui
malheureusement un bois de fond se
repose et la bête le rattraper mais
j'aime bien l'origine des noms mais il
s'y est opposée moi qui n'aime pas
beaucoup la chasse au gras dans le tarn
de fond se repose et bien jeune cette
expression d'accord alors ce livre vous
dites que c'est ni un ni un catalogue ni
ni attendait au secours ni un panorama à
ninon c'est que le p 10 est ce qu'on
peut parler d'une sorte de moi j'ai eu
besoin de me promener avec vous de
vagabondage comme ça de forêt en forêt
et puis tout d'un coup hop on a envie de
parler des lapins ou qu'on a envie de
parler de la fontaine hop on aurait
parlé d'un crime vous venez de prononcer
le mot juste c'est une promenade c'est
une promenade où je vous invite à
découvrir à mes côtés les forêts que
j'aime en france la forêt des cévennes à
la forêt des landes merveilleuse la
forêt mystérieuse de brocéliande donc
c'est une invitation à une promenade
dans les plus belles forêts de france
oui mais en toute liberté avec des
petits détours et des anecdotes il y en
ait beaucoup d'histoires comme
d'habitude parce que vous adorez
d'histoire et un ce qu'on réalise c'est
que déjà il ya plusieurs siècles parfois
les forêts étaient en danger il fallait
réagir coli sont n'en parlant qu'elles
ont toujours été en danger oui ni non
aux parfums moi j'y passais par une
surexploitation email gêné que au
moyen-âge avait beaucoup moins de forêts
qu'aujourd'hui ça devenait dramatique à
tel point que les rois de france sont
les premiers à faire des textes pour
protéger les forêts ensuite y'a colbert
qui va interdire à ce que l'on autorise
les pots-de-vin à mettre le sabot dans
les pieds je suis pas de sûreté des
sables pour les vaches mais m les pâtes
dans les dents dans les forêts pour les
préserver et c'est lui qui va ordonner
la plantation de milliers d'hectares
pour pour avoir des arbres qui en se
développant fourniront à l'industrie
pour les cathédrales les chapelles les
bateaux l'armement de magnifiques arbres
mais il est vrai que l'ancêtre de l'eau
nf est inventée par que par colbert
d'autres rois avant avec ben oui oui
avait décidé de mettre un terme à la
surexploitation des forêts est
aujourd'hui la forêt française en terme
de surface a retrouvé des dimensions
tout à fait louable attention le danger
persiste avec les maladies les incendies
le
l'urbanisation à outrance le
réchauffement climatique etc la forêt
n'est pas tirés d'affaires ouais pas se
reposer et alors vous parlez aussi c'est
là faudrait deux heures je me trompe
toujours entre fontainebleau rambouillet
c'est mon côté dit c'est
exploiter alors pour ces pierres pour
son pétrole c'est la forêt de
fontainebleau qui était très exploité
pour les pavés entre autres qui ont
permis justement de revêtir les routes
parisiennes mais j'en profite parce que
vous vous êtes parler de fond ce report
je voulais parler de rambouillet et vous
n'êtes pas les deux fontaines d'eau je
vous soupçonne peut-être d'être un peu
royalistes et vous avez raison car ce
sont les rois qui ont permis que l'on
ait autant de forêt parce qu'ils
souhaitaient chasser et qu'on savait le
couvert végétal et c'est l'ouest
parisien pas l'ampleur nous sommes à
autant de forêt à rambouillet à
versailles marly à saint germain on le
doit au roi qui ne voulaient pas
détruire ces zones boisées pour pouvoir
les choses pour leur plaisir de dallas
mais il est vrai en revenant à
fontainebleau que la forêt a souffert
une sur fréquentation on y exploiter du
pétrole en guise afp et la feuille que
ce soit des artistes qui les premiers
s'émeuvent de massacre de la forêt est
en haut des peintres de milliers en
particulier à qui l'on doit le
merveilleux tableaux de l'angélus et
mais bon oui coraux et victor hugo
victor ont signé une pétition pour dire
arrêtez de massacrer cette forêt qui est
quand même l'une des plus belles de
france avec ses pains ces rochers et son
sable a bien sûr donc réellement faut
jamais se relâcher et j'ai l'impression
que vous maintenant très beau livre
c'est plus ample de plus en plus comme
si votre mission c'est bien sûr donner
envie de connaître la nature et pensez
vraiment à la protéger de manière
positive cdh écolo c'est positif j'en ai
assez de tout ce qui nous rabâchent
toute la journée nos droits et
obligations j'en ai assez de tous ces
pseudo écologistes qui nous rappelle de
manière plus active ce que l'on peut ou
non pas faire non non on aime on ne
respecte que ce que l'on aime déjà ce
que je voudrais c'est donner envie aux
citoyens qui nous regardent que nous
écoute d mais la nature des mails forêts
des médias hélas ce jour là et bien les
arbres et les forêts seront sauvés très
bien d'ailleurs vous même vous dit que
l'amour de votre métier est venu grâce
aux vieux arbres à votre amour des vieux
arbres dont vous êtes entre huy à
versailles oui comme vous gardez un
cosmos - dahlia la flore est
certainement très belle mais de là à
fabriquer une histoire une histoire
d'amour avec cette plante il faut être
très imaginatif mais quand vous avez
devant vous un chêne planté dans la
forêt de fontainebleau il ya trop 400
ans quand vous avez des milliers de pins
clients de la fois des landes avec la
discussion est tout autre et claire il
ya vraiment de quoi tomber en extase
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui vous
émeut quand vous y avez vieillard vous
parce que moi je sais pourquoi savons
pas si fort parce que je sais que les
sommes sûrs que cette violence oui un
arbre il respire elle se nourrit de se
multiplient et je me dis que peut-être
qu'elle est capable de se souvenir et
quand j'ai deux voies mois devant moi un
arbre qui à 300 400 ans je me dis mais
que pourrait-il me raconter s'il était
doué de parole et c'est tarbes même côté
les morts continue par son bois de vivre
à travers l'objet qu'il va l'écrire donc
je suis et ému par les arbres carla non
content d'être devant moi d'être le
témoin du temps passé et du temps à
venir non content d'être beau non
content de purifier l'atmosphère de
retenir la terre en cas de d'inondations
eh bien ces tables et j'ai besoin de lui
pour vivre donc je suis admiratif des
armes capables de vivre au même
emplacement sans se plaindre pendant des
milliers d'années il ya quand même de
quoi être admiratif je comprends
d'accord et dites moi pourquoi est-ce
que vous comparez la forêt une famille
nombreuse vous établissez un parallèle
alors vous êtes
sept enfants cet enfant effectivement
vous savez de quoi vous parlez
de la famille nombreuse via des frères
et des soeurs qu'ils s'entendent plus ou
moins avec les parents parfois cela peut
bardet mais il y a un objectif commun il
faut que la famille soit heureuse la
forêt est exactement identique
vous avez des arbres de différentes
familles ont différentes variétés mais
ils ont un seul objectif être ensemble
pour faire que l'ensemble de la forêt se
porte bien et a besoin mais bien dans
les forêts les armes ne se gênent pas
les a vous avez des autres il
s'accompagne ils fournissent de l'undd
de l'ombre à ceux qui en ont besoin il
ya une sorte d'unité et bien qui fait
plaisir à voir et qui devrait aux
familles mais même à un état tout entier
ou ne savent l'emploi c'est vrai qu'un
bon modèle oui tout va très bien et
alors il ya un mot que j'ai trouvé très
bizarre la dendre aux latrines qu'est ce
que c'est la drôle attritionnel d'indre
la tribe ladro c'est le grec qui
signifie arbre et je crois tout
simplement enfin je crois que j'affirme
eux-mêmes que lada draw la tri s'est
tout simplement quand on a pour la une
passion excessive voire exagérée et où
j'aurai américains n'ont pas les mêmes
c'est de l'amour mais c'est quand on
donne où on prétend que les arbres ont
plus de pouvoir qu'il ne peut être
réellement il faut parfois garder raison
les apps sont capables de merveilles
incontestablement peut-être même deux
miracles ils sont pour certains capables
de ville de vivre mille ans voire plus
mais il faut de temps en temps se
souvenir que les arbres sont aussi faits
pour nous fournir du bois que nous
permet de nous chauffer de cuir nos
aliments de bâtir de maisons dont aider
les âmes oui les exploiter oui encore
faut-il le faire avec raison je
comprends et alors pourquoi est ce que
vous vous relevez d'ailleurs que dans le
vocabulaire de la justice il y à tout un
pan de mots qui correspondent à la forêt
alors le barreau la barre la langue de
bois le bâtonnier mais pourquoi ça ne ce
que les papas ils la plainte
parce que le vélo mais je me suis
inventé les autres fois à l'époque
naturel de justice doj ou rappeler que
ces salles oui on le sait tous ce qui
rendait la justice sous un chêne
et il y avait dans toutes les villes de
france généralement sur la place du
village un arbre sous lequel les sages
les anciens se réunissaient on pourra
les décisions de justice au pays basque
par exemple il ya la chaîne de guernica
sous lequel le roi d'espagne est
supposée venir prêter serment de
garantir les droits au peuple base que
donc effectivement le monde de la
justice est inspiré du monde végétal du
monde de cela seulement du bois parce
que c'est dans le bois que l'on trouve
la justice que l'on trouve l'égalité est
ce un hasard si la légion d'honneur a
pour emblème principal les feuilles de
chêne ce sont ces mêmes feuilles de
chêne qui en est le képi des généraux
donc effectivement le monde de l'arbre
est un peu partout dans la société qui
nous entoure le monde de la justice où
il a davantage mis en évidence que les
autres les autres corporations travées
un
parfait et bien écoutez continuons
prenons les arbres pour modèle oui et
puis régalons nous avec ce tour de
france des bois et forêts donc à l'ombre
rafraîchissant un grand merci pour ce
lien nous avoir entraîné avec vous dans
vos promenades c'est toujours très
agréable et instructif c'est un plaisir
et à l'an prochain pour le prochain mais
quelle sera la prochain je ne vous le
diront
ah non je vais attendre il faut
l'exclure alors au boulot mois de
vacances en attendant à bout cela très
vite merci à la merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis très bientôt pour un
nouveau vip 1
[Musique]